[Music]
you think you have a busy day
just wait till you find out what an
astronaut's schedule looks like
one thing's for sure it's not just
having fun floating around in zero
gravity or having the most spectacular
view of the planet anyone's ever seen
believe it or not from eating and
brushing their teeth
to working and sleeping pretty much
every move an astronaut makes
is scheduled in fact according to nasa
their schedules are planned
down to five minute increments the
occupants of the international space
station
or the iss perform several tasks as they
orbit the earth
making sure every job fits perfectly
into each astronaut's schedule
isn't always easy there are many
variables to account for
including for when the iss is in the
dark and when it's in the light
in the differing time zones for the
mission controls in houston and russia
welcome back to our channel today we're
going to take a look at a day in the
life
of an astronaut if you haven't already
make sure you hit that subscribe button
and ring the bell
so you never miss an upload from us the
11 people floating 400 kilometers above
our heads in the international
space station have a routine that is
almost recognizable to us but at the
same time
quite different from ours let's start in
the morning the 6am wake-up call for the
crew
you would have spent the night floating
in a sleeping bag in a cubicle the size
of a phone booth on the ceiling
once you've woken up the day starts the
same as it does on earth you flip
over and scroll instagram and tick-tock
for a few hours
no just kidding you get up and brush
your teeth but it's a little different
in space
you realize how much you take gravity
for granted when you have to work
without it you can't be running water
because it will go all over the place
so you have to squeeze a ball of water
out of a bag to wet your toothbrush
then you use regular toothpaste and
clean your teeth but where do you spit
well
you don't you swallow your toothpaste
it's edible and quite harmless
but probably not the easiest thing to
stomach then it's time for your morning
shower
astronauts clean up using items from
their personal hygiene
kit including what nasa calls their
rinseless shampoo
which was initially developed for
hospital patients who were unable to
take a shower
with just a little bit of water
astronauts comb the no rinse shampoo
through their hair to get it nice and
clean since there are no actual showers
in space
and since they don't drench their hair
in the little water they do use floats
away during the hair washing process
there's no need to break out the blow
dryer their hygiene kits also include
razors
and scissors so they can give each other
a haircut they just have to make sure
they vacuum up the hair
so it doesn't fly all over the place and
then it's time for the most important
meal of the day
breakfast being an astronaut sure works
up an appetite the tenants of the iss
are scheduled for three meals a day
breakfast lunch and dinner how much they
eat depends on the astronaut since
calorie requirements differ for each of
them
according to nasa a female astronaut
will need only about 1900 calories a day
while
a large male would need a maximum of 3
200 calories
as for how long it takes for them to eat
well that depends on what they're eating
and the meal prep time some snacks like
brownies and fruit can be eaten just how
they come
so that's a good option if an astronaut
is looking to refuel quickly
but some things like spaghetti or mac
and cheese need water to be added since
the food is dehydrated typically
the food is already prepared on earth
and you just need to reheat it one thing
you might be happy about being in space
is you never have to do dishes all the
food comes in disposable packaging so
you'll never have to clean another plate
at least while you're up there and then
it's time to get to work
after wrapping up your morning routine
you begin your assignments for the day
depending on what nasa gives you
the mission control center on the ground
sends instructions via email
or voice message to the astronauts each
day about any work that may need to be
done around the space station
the iss is designed to be a permanent
orbiting research facility
and the astronauts who orbit the earth
on the iss help carry out those research
efforts
you would be spending your days working
on science experiments that require you
to monitor projects controlled from the
ground
and take part in medical experiments to
figure out how well your bodies adjust
to living in space for long periods of
time
since astronauts live where they work
it's also their responsibility to help
keep the iss in tip-top
shape so much like you have to clean
your house and keep your living space
neat and tidy
astronauts also are tasked with
regularly checking support systems
cleaning filters updating computer
equipment disinfecting surfaces
and even taking out the trash almost
every task
on the station is very carefully laid
out and your to-do list outlines every
activity step by step
even still things sometimes get off
track some astronauts spend their first
few days on the space station just
losing stuff so they have to get used to
using velcro
clips magnets and tape to secure their
things
you can't not stay in shape in space
floating around is all fun and games
but it also poses long-term risks to
your health lack of gravity makes your
bones brittle and because
moving around is so effortless you will
also start losing
strength in your muscles to put it
simply our bodies are constantly working
because they are posing the gravity here
on earth
but that's not a problem in space so
astronauts must spend at least two hours
a day on fitness
they typically do some cardio and they
lift weights lots of it actually
lifting 200 pounds might be tough on
earth but in the weightless environment
of space
200 pounds is no problem there are three
main
pieces of equipment you can work out
with a treadmill a bike without a seat
since you can't sit without gravity and
the advanced resistive exercise device
or arad for short arad is a weight
lifting gym that uses vacuum tubes to
work without weights right about now it
would be lunchtime
weeks in space are still divided into
weekends and weekdays
so during the week each astronaut
follows their own schedule
so they rarely eat together the
exception of course is sundays when the
whole crew comes together to enjoy a
meal
group meals like these are essential for
crew morale since it can get pretty
boring and lonesome up there
remember how we said the food comes to
space already cooked on earth
these are dehydrated meals that come in
pouches to which hot water is added
before eating they also come in cans
that can be heated before
opening if you'll miss ketchup and hot
sauce they've got you covered but things
like salt and pepper are a tad
different they're in liquid form they
have to be or else you will have grains
of salt floating around the station
cargo missions often also send up fresh
fruit which is quite a treat for the
astronauts
want to go for a quick walk outside
after your meal well you'll have to
spend four hours putting on a suit
before you can do that you will also
have to run through a safety checklist
that is almost a hundred pages long
it's unavoidable sometimes your job will
entail repairing parts outside of the
station
once outside you could spend about eight
hours running through a series of tasks
if you aren't going on a spacewalk and
making incredible memories
you will likely be in the laboratory
running experiments
the primary purpose of the existence of
the iss
is to act as a unique research lab and
each astronaut spends a considerable
part of their day as zero gravity lab
technicians for scientists on earth
there are five lab modules on board
russia has two many research modules
america's lab is called destiny europe
has columbus
and the newest one is japan's kibo which
also has a platform outside the station
for experiments
the experiments they set up and record
include checking the impact of zero
gravity on living cells
explosions small animals and different
materials but more often
than not the astronauts themselves are
the subjects of these tests
the iss aims to discover the long-term
effects of zero gravity on the human
body so we can better plan for longer
space missions
and travel to mars sounds hectic don't
worry
you still get free time you can call or
email your family from the space station
read watch movies and even play
instruments but we doubt you will want
to do anything other than watch the
earth spin beneath you
there's no better feeling than climbing
into bed after a long day of work
at least that's something we have in
common with astronauts but instead of
beds you get cozy in a sleeping bag
attached to the wall
otherwise they'd be floating around all
night all astronauts are scheduled
for a good eight hours of sleep per
night but if you have trouble falling
asleep
you can spend that time chatting with
family back home
or reading so would you want to spend a
week in space after knowing an
astronaut's daily schedule
let us know in the comments below if you
enjoyed this video
give us a like and check out more videos
like it on the simply tech channel
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time